The sauce. Kevin here with a message about your online existence.
Social media is a venomous snake pit of linguistic diarrhea
and keyboard garbage because no one can agree on what
knowledge is actually knowledge,
no matter what the post or video or tweet or argument is
about. No matter what side they're on,
no matter what they believe,
someone else knows they're wrong,
they don't know anything.
How can two people be both so confident that they know something
when they've reached totally different conclusions,
obviously, right?
Weird. Is that it seems pretty simple to know something. I mean,
you just know it,
you know it because you have some kind of relevant experience or, you know,
someone who does, and they transferred that knowledge to you,
or maybe you've read something you trust or you know,
that what an expert in a particular field says is valid.
However, it comes to you,
that information is an accurate description of the way the
world is that's knowledge. Right?
Right.
Sometimes the way we tend to think about knowledge is in terms of justified
true belief,
a concept that goes back to Plato's dialogue between Socrates and
Theotis in three 69 BC,
and was actually refined and codified by 20th century philosophers,
it's a little more modern than it seems,
but it's exactly what it sounds like to know something you need to have
justification for what sort of evidence tells you it's
right.
Is there enough of it are the odds in its favor and it needs
to be true. Is it reality for you and for others?
Does it really hold up to scrutiny?
Truth is pretty weird in that it's metaphysical.
It's about how things are not necessarily what you see.
We don't even have to verify something for it to be true,
quick pick heads or tails go.
I'm never, ever going to look at the result of this coin flip,
but half of you predicted the true outcome,
and then you've got to leave it and you have to recognize it as being
true and justified. Look, here's a very simple example.
You look at a clock to find out the time because clocks tell
time you're justified in thinking a clock is going to tell you
the time the clock says 3:00 PM,
which you believe because it's always been right for,
and this is what clocks do.
It's true because it's actually 3:00 PM. So congratulations.
You know, it's 3:00 PM.
All of this makes sense.
What I've just described as a formal examination of what we
all do pretty much all the time,
but I can prove your justified true
belief. Your knowledge can be an illusion for
thousands of years.
Understanding of what knowledge is was considered etched in stone
case closed until in 1963, philosopher,
Edmund GetEater wrote a short three page paper that completely
smashed the justified true belief simulation.
It was such a shift in how we think about knowledge that philosopher
Alvin Plantinga said 1993,
that knowledge is justified. True belief.
So thought from time in Memorial, then God said,
let Getty or be not quite all was light, perhaps,
but at any rate we learned, we had been standing in a dark corner.
How getting your claimed that we can satisfy all three
of those conditions and still not actually know something.
Let's revisit our clock example.
We looked at a clock that read 3:00 PM and had knowledge.
It was 3:00 PM because it satisfied. Plato's justified,
true belief definition.
What if the clock was broken and stuck at 3:00 PM?
Do you actually know the time from looking at a broken
clock, even if it's accidentally, correct?
No. Like N O no, not Kenya. No.
W no, no. That is justified.
True belief without knowledge.
That is a Getty or provenance, or think of it like this.
There is a cat in this YouTube video out in
sheriff cat here. Ah,
just mosey down into this too big town to restore a bit of order.
You see this here, wobbling John tender.
Foot's been yarn in the hours away with too much mustard.
And I am the set thing straight of aura.
The whole corral turns into a bag of nuts.
I haven't been outside in four months. Anyway,
there's a cat in this YouTube video. You know,
there's a YouTube video because you're watching me record it.
You're on YouTube right now. Your looking at sheriff cat,
you're justified in thinking there's a cat in this video,
you can decide it's true with confidence.
And you believe what your seeing, everything here adds up
and you were right. There has been a cat in this video this whole time.
You were just right for the wrong reasons. And yeah,
you were right. But did you know it is that knowledge,
is that knowledge Luna they'll figure it out.
They'll figure out what knowledge is. No, of course. It's not knowledge.
You knew nothing. You had a justified true belief.
It was accurate, but it wasn't. So even when you're right,
how do you know you're not actually wrong? This calls into question,
the scientific method, what we think we know about the natural world,
everything given the ease and prevalence of Getty or problems,
we can't possibly know anything. Right?
Hello.
Wrong. Well, mostly wrong.
This is how it actually works. Okay. As scientists,
we have a hypothesis.
We wonder if something is true or not true.
We propose an experiment. If the experiment supports the hypothesis,
they would say, well, maybe my idea was true,
but I could be biased. Maybe there's a flaw in my experiment.
Maybe the electrical current had a glitch in the mid point of taking
data.
Yeah. But that's exactly the kind of uncertainty I'm talking about.
I experiment again,
I try to design a different kind of experiment to test for the same idea.
I get a colleague of mine to test it.
I get them to come up with a new kind of experiment.
I get a competitor of mine to,
to try to show that I'm wrong with an experimental design of
their own.
And if all of those experiments give approximately the
same answer, because there will be statistical variation,
I think it was approximately the same answer. We're onto something. Okay.
Okay. Okay.
So in science you take what seems to be knowledge and then start to eliminate
all those other possibilities to distill what you think, you know.
In the methods and tools of science as they're applied to that question.
Right? So we learn earth goes around the sun.
That's not going to later on be shown to be false ever,
ever. We got that one.
Now you can ask more refined questions. Okay.
What kind of orbit does it have? Is it a perfect circle?
It's a good approximation, but it's not exactly right.
So you can ask deeper questions. Yes. It does go around the sun.
What kind of a circle is it? Is it a squash circle? Is it a long gated?
Is it that?
And you keep doing this and what you end up doing is refining the answer to the
question to a level that satisfies your needs in the
moment.
Yes. So that's how knowledge builds and expands.
So maybe it's not so much what we don't know as what we
keep finding out.
So you can say, well, we never know anything. Yes.
We know a lot of things. Will we ever know anything.
Perfectly? Well.
There are certain things you can ask where you're just counting things. Yes.
You can note perfectly.
There's certain crystals where we know exactly where all the atoms are,
where all the atoms are and we can count them.
We know exactly how many atoms there aren't a crystal, certain crystals. Yes.
There are certain answers that are precise, but if it involves a measurement,
no, you can, it can be ever more refined,
but there could be a point where more refinement just doesn't matter to
the aspect of the answer that you're seeking.
So in science, we are perfectly content when multiple experiments agree,
even if the philosopher isn't, even if the philosopher is distracted,
by the possibility that there might be a deeper truth
lurking within the data that we have accumulated,
I don't have a problem with it.
Yeah.
I guess we can hit a point where we know as much as we want to or need
to. And when we hit the end like that,
we've moved on to something else.
Science is a continuous journey
through the main of nature. And,
but not all information is equally uncertain. That's my only point here.
And so we know how to fly.
We know how wheels work well in all the other machines in physics,
we know how electricity works. We have,
this is why we can use a phone.
I got an old fashioned phone here. It's an I, this works to say,
we can't really know. We do know. That's why, that's why you're living longer.
That's why so many things are different about your life today,
then how your ancestors live.
Because the methods and tools of science have been applied to questions that
curious people have asked for, for the most part,
for the betterment of society and for civilization. So, so no,
I'm not going to wallow in some prospect that we can never know
anything we do.
And if you want to think way, just move back to the cave.
Cause that's really where you belong.
Nah, I like, uh, indoor plumbing. Hey Neil. Uh, while I've got you,
there's a question that's been killing me for years. It's very,
very simple.
You got a question after all that. Okay. What is.
Okay, ready is a hot dog, a sandwich.
I have vowed many years ago to never
get into an argument with someone of the definition of a word,
all kinds of people love doing this. I remember growing up,
is it a gum or is it a candy? Is it lighter? Is it less filling?
Is I'm saying, no,
I'm not going there because ideas matter to me more than
the words we come up with to describe them.
Okay. But I need to know, we need to categorize this.
Just because the brain is, is, is but yours,
but all of our collective brains want to categorize things.
And if something spilled out of one category, we fight about where it belongs.
I'm saying, no, I'm not having that fight. I'm not having that fight. In fact,
if you want to go there, just invent a new category,
call it the hot dog category. Okay?
It's not a sandwich. It's a don't get up. I'd be happy with that. Otherwise, no,
I'm not spending time arguing.
Is it a non bread food sitting between two surfaces of bread?
It's a sandwich.
Ha, there you have it. So this wasn't even plugged into anything. Anyway,
the Getty, your problem exists and knowledge is a lot more complicated
than it seems. Excuse me, sheriff cat, happy trails.
Sometimes knowledge is straightforward and irrefutable.
Sometimes it's murky.
Sometimes we're right and wrong at the same time.
And sometimes we hit the practical limits of our curiosity and
shouldn't really bother getting any more granular than that.
Like Neil says at a certain point, it's time to move on.
And till we decide,
we need to go back in 1972,
WV Quine,
who I referenced in the what is a paradox video wrote an essay specifically
dedicated to the limits of knowledge. He opens it by asking,
are there things that man can never know?
And Roger Shattuck,
a writer and literary professor explored the consequences of understanding
24 years later in his book, forbidden knowledge,
including starting off the entire thing with a seminal question to the human
experience.
Are there things we should not know?
And what about Getty or who inspired a revolution in how think
about thought philosopher.
John L Polich concluded that Getty or single handedly changed. The course.
Systemology get yours 92 years old.
Now he never published another thing after that paper,
not a word when asked why all he said was I have
nothing more to say,
apparently also invented the mic drop.
It's been.
24 Years since Shaddox book.
And my answer to all the questions asked by Shaddock
Quine giddier and Plato is, I don't know.
And yes, social media is nuts.
But the other day I was reading a thread by Simon [inaudible].
He's a professor at Carnegie Mellon and runs the laboratory for social minds at
the Santa Fe Institute,
he was talking about knowledge and justified true belief. And he said,
one reason he likes doing science with others is because they can help him
disprove something.
He believes more efficiently than he can himself.
He said that works best because we need help in exploring the
unknown. If you're walking in the woods,
you can either walk towards a landmark or away walking
away for some reason.
Seems to work better. That's what we're.
Doing all the time,
where identifying the known and exploring the unknown.
We struggle with imperfect knowledge and whether it's science,
philosophy, cats, or hotdogs to get to where we're going.
Sometimes you just need to walk away and as
always, thanks for watching.
[Inaudible].
So sheriff cat, do you arrest like humans or you just arrest other cats?
Do rescue dogs. Like how does this work?
Hold on. Hello.
You can watch more of Neil and I discussing the boundaries of knowledge and
science over on star talk.
Make sure you subscribe to star talk while you're there. It is wonderful.
Also the summer curiosity box has dropped and you can start thinking
now by getting yours@curiositybox.com it's made by
the sauce, and this is the subscription for thinkers.
So basically.
Bye.